[Music]
our next guest is a comedian who can be
seen live at zany's comedy club in
chicago from august 8th through the 11th
and whose showtime special what's wrong
with people is available now on dvd
please welcome very funny sebastian
maniscalco
[Music]
[Applause]
oh good to be here
um helping my buddy move yesterday just
gonna put the rest of the stuff up on
craigslist
anybody been to this website
it looks like it came out when the
internet came out
but you want to put up some flash
looks like braille i mean
and i don't know why people are doing
this what are you out of your mind
you're gonna put up a couch
for 23 dollars
and you're going to wait for someone to
come murder you and your entire family
just put it right area rug for sale come
stab me and the neighborhood i mean
i don't know i grew up in an italian
family we don't trust nobody okay
we had a garage sale growing up we were
we were nervous to even do that
we had a meeting you know you want to
have this sale yeah we'll try it right
and we just threw the garbage
out on the driveway
put a couple signs all over the
neighborhood come get our garbage
and the weirdest people would show up at
the house
they'd be waiting in the street
and you just watch this dysfunction
happen all over your property
right they look at your son
and some of them a little too close
they'd come a little too close to the
house you'd have to tell them hey back
up back up back up ask me from there
what you want i got kids here
can we share bathroom bathroom get off
the property
it's not walmart
you pick it and go back to the cave you
crawled out
and whatever we didn't sell we threw it
out
but we broke it before we put it in the
garbage
it's my italian father's like if they're
not going to buy it at my sale they're
not going to come by later and steal it
out of that garbage
saw the couch in half why
he had a whole thing he's like you know
burn the lamps
pop the eyeballs out of this teddy bear
and then decapitate the head
sort of head out on monday and then the
body out on saturday
peace it out over the week
the world's changing
i don't think it's for the better
everybody's walking around tattoos body
art what's it
guys will do it a lot they'll get one
right on the bicep
now every shirt becomes a sleeveless
they gotta billboard the tattoo
because there's like a special meaning
behind it
you'll get some idiot that comes up to
the guy excuse me what's the
significance
why do you have a cobra head on your
bike
now the guy gets all emotional he's like
thanks for asking
what it is it's a cobra head and the
reason i got it
my father got bit by a snake okay
it's not done yet it's never done they
got to go back right
2025 i'm gonna have the entire snake all
over my body
but for now it's just ahead but what's
gonna happen it's gonna come across my
chest
cascade down my torso the tail's gonna
wrap around my nut bag
i don't laugh it's for my dad
it's gonna creep around my back the
rattle's gonna take up my nipple
out of my nipple is going to say dead
rest in peace you know
what the hell are you doing to yourself
what did you forget he died
what do you look down oh yeah
people ask me all the time sebastian why
don't you have a tattoo why
i don't put bumper stickers on ferraris
that's my time you have to be great
that was really funny
great job sebastian mennis calco legend